oh snap it is December 8th 2008 um thank
you guys well I'm sure some of you do
remember I used to do me today videos
talking about my day just like that
whatever you know lots of fun
blah blah blah um just gonna put this on
here for my video cuz it's a little
chilly
um what's been going on well probably
since my last me today video which was
probably approximately not sure no can't
be that long maybe like six months
longer than that no no either way that's
a long time um yesterday I went to
Disney for the first time Disney Disney
World but you know we might which is new
in Disney World is in Florida if I just
put Eva in here
I put weight where she's right there
she's like my face um dude just he's fun
I had a really good time definitely she
got good back I got an annual pass so
anybody misses going on um oh I have
this really terrible addiction to a
cream soda which I just finished this
bottle I'm not happy it's really good
it's really really good I shouldn't be
drinking this it's a little more healthy
um I know it's good to be in LA I
finally officially have a home you know
I mean I've been kind of living here off
and on for the past few years but I
haven't signed that little Lea
sign my little name on the paper that
says hello I live here
this is my home hello welcome I don't
have a welcome mat hi I mean I can get
well now because this is my place I can
put a welcome mat out and I can welcome
people here if I so choose to do that
but you probably won't because I think
welcome mats are kind of lame actually
do yourself welcome lots of jealous
sorry sorry if you do hmm oh speaking of
addictions
these are d drives guys actually he's
full but backing up some fouls on him
this one was 350 gigs so I believe
there's bass on that speaking of hard
drives not too happy with my MacBook Pro
right now every time I restart it which
I believe this is because I have a bunch
of hard drives daisy chained together
and they're all hooked up and my
computers like what's up
which harddrive do I start from well you
should know which hard drive you start
from it's the one that is built in to
your little body what do you think this
is it's freaking 2008 soon-to-be 2009 I
don't need to tell you what's harder to
start out from you should know damn well
we're just her oh you should question
mark for you know that why should work
folder this one
hmm makes me so so angry well that felt
good um don't someone else I got going
on Oh Oh the ocarina iPhone application
I am obsessed and let me tell you not to
be cocky or anything but I'm pretty
freaking oh yeah God do you think that
you can play the ocarina better the main
because guess what I don't think that
you can actually I know that you can't
because I have been practicing all night
and let me tell you this I can play
every single holiday song perfectly
almost perfectly better than you can
right right okay anyway me and my
extremely large comfortable hoodie are
gonna go maybe take a walk
oh it's actually getting kind of late
it's like eat a clock maybe I should
take a walk but I'm kind of hungry so
maybe I'll take a walk for some food I
don't know either way that was uh that
was me today okay
oh one last thing which I was actually
gonna dress this in a blog post or tweet
actually I did tweet about it um thanks
to everybody for sending me tons and
tons of feedback regarding my my show
ideas that's funny because a lot of your
ideas were things that I have been
thinking about in the past
like really
do that and then well you know what you
guys just reiterated that so guess what
maybe I'll do some of them maybe I'll do
all of them a new show a day the random
way do you the choices anyway that's it
was a 506 minute video six minutes in
right now about six minutes lots of talk
about nothing and wonder who's gonna get
mad that I posted this to my main
YouTube channel guess what I don't care
okay mmm and now I would say start and
stop